ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata fra una
settimana è pasqua ed è per questo che
ho deciso di fare un uovo di pasqua
della kinder a casa da solo si cita
1234567 sette persone di cui una che sta
suonando il pianoforte nell'altra stanza
comunque per fare l'uovo di pasqua della
kinder avremo bisogno di si comincia non
lo abbiamo mangiato e cioccolato bianco
non lo abbiamo mangiato ci sono un sacco
di tutorial che parlano dei palloncini
che fanno vedere come utilizzare questi
sono quelli piccoli piccoli in azioni di
assistente c'è palla un sacco di
tutorial per fare facilmente le uova a
casa usano i palloncini
partiamo dal presupposto che per quanto
tu li possa lavare gonfiare e sgonfiare
secondo me secondo me sono mezzi nocivi
abbiamo abbandonato il divertimento del
vecchio di palloncini dott bene per
evitare di morire subito dopo e
utilizzeremo invece una formina per uova
è molto semplice da trovare in
descrizione ho messo un pochino di link
più economici o meno la prima ma se
dovevano fare quindi è temperare il
cioccolato e cospargere la parte esterna
diciamo dei gusci con il cioccolato al
latte aspetteremo che si riscaldi ti
aspettiamo che si raffreddi e poi sempre
remo il cioccolato bianco e faremo un
altro strato con londra a coprire
totalmente per fare quelle fettine ma
aspettando sempre che si riscaldi anche
quello guardiamo subito temperare il
cioccolato non è una cosa facilissima ma
ci sono un bel po di tutorial
dov'è il mio telefono io senza quello
che riesco a cucinare a è vero al
grembiule pure pallotta
resta il telefono
[Applauso]
ora tu hai paura dei palloncini ce ne
abbiamo tanti e non ne stiamo facendo
scoppiare nemmeno uno questo qui il
robert o metros e roberta stava per fare
qualcosa
oggi devo trovare i vostri punti deboli
casa pulita
qual è il cioccolato al latte deve
raggiungere i 45 50 gradi
e poi dobbiamo far scendere a 27
utilizzeremo un termometro da cucina
anche qua sotto vi ho messo nell infobox
la possibilità di acquistarlo su amazon
dobbiamo sciogliere a bagnomaria ma
perché è così tante ciotole cioè dovete
sciogliere un sacco di cose a bagnomaria
vabbè l'acqua non tocca il pentolino a
bagnomaria
se questo qui è il procedento sbagliato
quello che ho detto gianmarco la colpa è
sua
come fai a fare l'acqua se non
recipiente come fa a fare l'albero senza
il seme oggi sto andando un pochino più
si sta arrivando la pasqua e quindi mi
sento più è preferibile che l'acqua del
pentolino non sfiori il fondo della
bastardella in cui avrete messo il
cioccolato jones no non lo sfiora
perfetto
quanto su questo servirà per la cosa
difficile raffreddarlo devi stare lì con
la spatola le cose che non abbiamo
niente tutto questo quindi proveremo a
raffreddarlo un metodo alternativo m
cioccolatiere set io metto questo me lo
sto tranquillo e sereno
[Musica]
così lanciando si è mangiato qualcosa
del genere mentre faccio uno è l'ora
freddo girando un phon
quindi facciamo un bagno maria contrario
da bagno giuseppe cioè io sto giocando
con la testa dell'uomo focaccina
troviamo lo chiamo atleta del grande
hermano sto sbagliando tutto
se come stiamo salendo troppo per in 40
42 43 ci stiamo
donato io direi professionista in campo
e riso l'unica a spatola quindi alla
domanda è qual è invece una spatola
senza buchi cioccolato bianco deve
scendere fino a 27 il cioccolato al
latte e quello bianco deve salire a 45
poi scendere tra i 26 25 4
ma queste somme che ciò che si sposta
alla velocità del persone
è sempre 45 e 46 secondo me ci saranno
le persone i cioccolatieri che mi
diranno le fai però ragazze mali estremi
estremi rimedi
perdonate non abbiamo niente in primis
la volontà poi non so voi ragazzi per
quanto mi riguarda pasqua uguale walking
tutti gli altri buoni ma comunque un
gradino sotto fatemi sapere qual è il
vostro preferito
ma no ma c'è ancora tanto cioccolato qui
la fa mettere mi sento aver fatto una
sciocchezza quindi dovevamo arrivare al
45 ma mi sono distratto sta salendo
vertiginosamente
questo qui sta diventando più una
pastella questo qui invece ancora super
liquido amore la sorpresa è piena del
mio amore per te hai paura che non sia
abbastanza grande luogo questo quasi
tipo quello dell'equità io 27 ragazzi
movimenti rotatori ricca di questo lo
stampino operatori di diga e poi tipo
come lei ghiaccio lei accetti prendiamo
a questo punto della carta forno e
lasciate riposare lo stampo a testa in
giù per una decina di minuti cercando
giuseppe rai
io faccio questa cosa sui nostri stessi
venta il precedente prova l'istanza
coprolalia tra gli ha dubbi però posso
dire per pasqua molto meglio cerca di
fare un uovo cioccolato che farsi
crocifiggere di parte di vigili del
falco anno dal riso riso lei è un po una
crocifissione questo io faccio una cosa
che non si dovrebbe fare ma non
interessa la scelta saggia
grazie 28 scendiamo di un grado e ogni
volta si gioisce un po come con la
febbre
2 gradi cosa sono due gradi che aveva
anche un analista possono fare seri
problemi venuti
io intanto vorrei staccarle non è così
facile non pensarlo è rosa ma anche
staccarle inter e cioè io so che tu hai
davanti a te un professionista e quindi
pensi che io possa fare tutto
non riesco a fare tutto marco viti sento
rimane 26 è temperato bene si sono molto
baci dati effettivamente è opaco
sì
[Musica]
e bello bellissimo ragazzi ho versato
questo cioccolato all'interno di un
cioccolato che stava in frigo c'è una
lotta spero che vinca il latte anche se
io preferisco il bianco
io non capisco come quando alcune
persone presenti e fondente non sono
persona
ok stiamo mettendo uno strato di norme
[Applauso]
ormai dei raffreddare
a questo punto facciamo partire il timer
per mezz'ora
l'uomo più fede è passata mezz'ora è
arrivato il momento quindi di ritirare
fuori le formine dal frigo
beh non è perfetto questo particolare
non sposi si nota dovrebbero levare
abbastanza la probabilmente a prendere
solo fisicamente tanto fare leva come
scusa ma che di chili ma che mangiamo il
prezzo la canzone tanto questa mi sembra
la roba migliore per rovinare il
perimetro ma lei chi che la ringraziamo
intanto però 91 rovini
lo dice lei ma sa di natura di sexy
scavando e basta e uova si staccano bene
nell'uovo si staccano bene
il punto critico più critico di questo
ma rimarrà per sempre così fallito
portatemi un phon caldo fila di un phon
e cosa possiamo fare la cosa possiamo
fare continua ragazzi sono teneri
spaccio compagno che faccio ascona
particamente quella molti non cedere io
dovevamo prenderli in silicone no non si
sa fa un macello ma non si stacca e
andato questo ormai il sapore della
prova non lo dico subito
era pazzesco
troviamo una soluzione la dissoluzione
ma che soluzione no un cucchiaio
guardate cucchiaio e questo è l'effetto
finale del dell'uomo che abbiamo fatto
ragazzi che dire
che dire i ragazzi secondo me c'è stato
un piccolo errore col cioccolato al
latte perché il bianco è perfettamente
duro quello al latte ha un non so che di
spugnoso lo vedevo assaggiare ragazza
come più basso e più basso e quindi più
appiccicoso comunisti per favore
foodblogger un usciti ammette io sto per
avere tra le visioni per quanto zucchero
campo non certo che può dire la pazienza
di far vedere nuovo presumono vedere che
sorpresa c'era dentro meno dimenticato
che loro chiuso questo anche per sette
ore
questo è il nostro pasqua dei consigli
per evitare che risulti questo stare
attenti ai procedimenti che fate molto
probabimente ho sbagliato qualcosa
perché uno è venuto bello duro l'altro
abbastanza molliccio un altro consiglio
che vi do e che vi metto anche qui
nell'info box prendete le formine per
fare luogo in silicone il fatto che
siano morbide aiuto ed un certo senso
mattina fuori luogo
terza cosa compratelo già fatto che
altro all'inter io intanto vi auguro no
non provo assaporare con anticipo gli
auguri o inoltre di auguri a chi scrive
quindi a questo canale di attivare la
campanera qua sotto per non perdere le
prossime puntate che ci saranno di
cucina buttata e che dire ci vediamo la
prossima domenica
ciao